لماذا
توقع هذه الاتفاقية ولماذا
تعتقد أن هذه الاتفاقية هي الطريق
إلى الأمام للسودان نحن نأسف
لكل إراقة الدماء
وفقدان
شعبنا ودماء السودان ثمينة للغاية
ولكننا نوقع هذه الاتفاقية على وجه التحديد
لتجنب
المزيد من إراقة الدماء
مزيد من الكوارث
التي نعيش فيها  منطقة
نعرفها جيدًا
إذا لم تخوض
في عملية جادة
للتوصل
إلى حل وسط من
شأنه أن يسمح
للأمور بالتطبيع
واستعادة البدائل
قد يكون
لها عواقب أكثر وقد تؤدي
إلى المزيد من إراقة الدماء ،
لذا فإن ما فعلناه
هو  على وجه التحديد لوقف
تنفيذ الضمانات الخاصة بهذه الاتفاقية ،
ليس لدينا فحص جانبي
للقول إنه سيتم
تنفيذها ولكن ذلك سيعتمد
على حسن نية كلا الجانبين
وعلى إرادة شعبنا
كما قلت ليس هناك الكمال.  الاتفاق
سوف نعالج
نواقصها
مشاكلها وأعتقد أننا سنضعها على
المحك ، والنتيجة النهائية
سيحددها الشعب السوداني
قبل ذلك بوقت طويل.  لقد قلت إنك
تعتمد على إرادة جميع الأطراف ، هل أنت
واثق من أن الجيش سوف
يلتزم بوعوده مع هذه الاتفاقية الجديدة ،
هذا هو نفس الجيش الذي
فك الاتفاق السابق ،
وحل الحكومة واعتقل
مسؤولين حكوميين وقتل العشرات.
من المتظاهرين الذين قتلوا صبيًا يبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
بعد ساعة فقط من توقيع الاتفاقية ،
هل
تعتقد حقًا أنهم
سيسلمون السلطة بشكل سلمي وآمن
إلى حكومة مدنية عندما
يحين الوقت
، وأعتقد
أننا
سنبدأ
العمل على  خارطة الطريق
في الأشهر الثمانية عشر القادمة
تكفي
لتنظيم
انتخابات ذات مصداقية ،
وسوف نحدد موعدًا ثابتًا وهو
الآن نتحدث عن يوليو
2023 ونعمل
إلى الوراء لإنشاء
خريطة طريق
عادلة ستقودنا إلى هذا
الموت وأنا  نعتقد
أننا سنؤسس تلك المعايير وسنتخذها واحدة تلو الأخرى
على
أمل أن يخلق هذا
الزخم لنا للوصول إلى
هذا
الخط المنقط